so far we've talked about how the fed
can control the money supply by
performing these open market
transactions where they're buying and
selling uh treasury securities but
you're probably asking well you know
when i read the the newspaper headlines
about all of this i don't hear about the
open market transactions so much and i
don't hear about them buying treasury so
much i always hear them setting the
federal funds rate or the discount rate
or the target rate and and what do these
words mean and how do these relate to
open market transactions so that's what
we'll we'll try to go over right now so
what we're going to focus on is the
target rate and in the probably in the
next video or a couple of more videos
we'll focus more on the discount rate
and there are two different things
although they're often used in
conjunction with each other and they're
they're kind of they move in tandem but
let's focus on the target rate because
this is how the the fed under normal
conditions
normally
sets its monetary policy so the target
rate
so just so you know the definition this
is the rate that the fed wants banks to
lend reserves to each other on a very
short term basis so overnight what does
that mean so i drew two banks here and i
do it a little bit different than i
normally do this the left hand side is
the assets
the
red box is the liabilities in this blue
over here this is the equity and the
thing that i did different
is every
every video so far i've been drawing the
reserves on the bottom of the
of the assets and that actually made a
little confusing when you compare the
reserves to the
to the demand deposits i'm assuming all
of the liabilities are demand deposits
that they're not taking other types of
loans so these are all checking accounts
all of this red area right here
so i actually finally figured out that
it would be easier to compare
the reserve ratios if i had it drawn
side by side so let's say this bank
right here these are its reserves in
green and these could be
dollars this could be actual cash that's
sitting in there in their vault or it
could be demand uh it could be reserved
deposits with the federal reserve
they're really the same thing and they
can go back and forth and i think that's
kind of you understand that now so and
just so you understand this
this asset is a liability of the federal
reserve maybe it's you know it's roughly
that much of it
so that's that
an asset for the bank liability for the
federal reserve and this reserve for
this bank is the liability of the
federal reserve
and if these were actually
cash if this was actually dollar bills
and this would say notes outstanding if
this asset is a demand deposit account
or reserve deposit account with the
federal reserve then this would just say
you know reserve account for bank b
with that said so this bank just
visually the way i've drawn it let me
just fill this in i think it looks nice
when i color in the squares
this bank its reserves just the way i've
drawn it are clearly its reserve ratio
is clearly lower than this bank because
this is its demand deposits this is its
reserves let's say that this bank has
reserves i'm just eyeballing it of
and that looks like about if you take
the ratio of this height
to this height it looks like it has
reserves of maybe
i'm just going to say 10
well this one looks more like it has i
don't know closer to 20 reserves
and i remember banks you know we talked
about regulation so there is some
minimum reserves that a bank needs to
keep and then of course even if there
were no regulation a bank would want to
keep some reserves just in case some of
these demand deposits people want their
cash so you would always want to keep
some reserves but you don't want to keep
too much reserves because what happens
with too much reserves reserves you
don't get any interest on a reserve
account or on cash and that's actually
how the if you're if you're curious how
the f how the fed actually supports
itself well it gives these banks reserve
accounts which are essentially checking
accounts at the fed and it gives them no
interest on it it gives them no interest
so it has no interest on the right hand
side of their balance sheet so it pays
no interest on its liabilities let me
and its liabilities are these things
right here it pays no interest on these
things
but it gets interest on some of its
assets so here i i drew a little bit of
gold
this yellow part is gold right here let
me write that gold
this this right here is gold and then i
this brown
color we'll assume that these are
treasuries right so if i have a
government treasury it gives me some
interest so i'm paying no interest if
i'm the fed i'm paying no interest on
this on these reserve deposits or on
these notes outstanding and i get
interest
on my assets
so that's that's easy money
and it actually turns out that what the
fed does and this kind of what this is
why is very ambiguous whether it's
really independent of the government or
not you know it is officially a private
institution but it's board of directors
it's appointed by the government and
and even more this money that it makes
any surplus money that it has after
paying all of the expenses of the
federal reserve it actually goes back to
congress so you know don't think that
somehow there's this private bank with
this great money making scheme because
all the money goes back to congress
although that goes both ways if for
whatever reason the fed were to do
really stupid things and it would become
insolvent congress is obligated we we
learned before that these these treasury
notes are obligations of the us
government so it goes both ways so even
though it's officially independent it
really isn't it really is almost a part
of congress or at least a part of a part
of a part of the government but with
that said
oh actually i should say part of the
treasury not so much part of congress
i'm i'm i don't want to be technically
incorrect but with that said let's go
back to this example with these two
banks so this guy he probably has more
reserves than he needs and he doesn't
like having too much reserves because
you don't get any interest on it let's
say that this guy he only he wants 15
percent reserves that he he figures that
that's that's more than enough that he
needs and this guy he he feels like he's
getting a little bit low on reserves he
would also like to get to 15 percent so
this guy would like to borrow this much
money this much
reserves right reserves would actually
be physical cash or reserve deposits
with the fed and this guy
he has
let me see let me draw another car he
has about this much to lend
right he has roughly about this much
right here to lend and so the obvious
thing since there's only two banks in
this universe is that this guy would
lend to that guy
probably overnight because you don't
know what's going to happen tomorrow
maybe some people are going to want
their money back etc so we're just
lending overnight and if this guy still
feels comfortable situation he can he
can continue that lending he could this
guy can renew his lending and this guy
will renew it whatever you get the idea
so the question is what interest rate
does this guy charge to that guy for
lending this little chunk of money let
me circle it again
for lending this chunk of money let me
do another shade of green
for lending this chunk of money
overnight to this to this bank
let's just say right now this bank says
i'll charge you i don't know i'll charge
you 10 percent
overnight
i'll charge you
10 percent to lend this money to you
overnight so it's not go it's not like
you're you're paying 10 just for a
one-night loan it's an annual rate of 10
so overnight you're paying some you know
this to the 1 365th power or however
many business days are so it's actually
a very small amount of interest these
are kind of the annual rates if this guy
were to continue borrowing it you know
overnight and overnight for a whole year
with that said let's say that the fed
decides that the money supply isn't big
enough that the fed wants to expand the
money supply so let's see what happens
in that situation so what how what was
that mechanism so what the fed does
is it can
print
it can print
notes
and so
either notes or let's just say it's
actually a physical cache
so there you go it prints some notes
that's an asset that the fed is holding
now
and of course it has an offset
offsetting liability now which is notes
outstanding
right
and then
what the fed does is it uses these notes
and it can buy treasuries it can buy
risk-free government
debt right so what it does is it and it
buys into the open market it buys you
know maybe that that debt might be being
held by china it might be being held by
your grandmother it could be being held
by anyone it might even be being held by
some of these banks but needless to say
they take this and they buy treasuries
with it
they buy treasuries with it so then that
asset then turns to treasuries on on the
fed's balance sheet
but where did all that cash go right
well that cash will then go to your
grandmother who was holding the
treasuries and what is your grandmother
going to do with that cash well your
grandmother is going to put that cash in
their bank right and maybe they're
buying it from a lot of people's
grandmothers
and so let's say some of the
grandmothers put the money
let's say some of the grandmothers put
the money in
this bank
right i'm trying to draw it so this bank
gets a little bit more reserves and then
some of the grandmothers put it in
this bank
over here
right that's what the open and so what
what happened what was the net effect of
that the government's balance sheet
increased a little bit if you look at
its total assets it's expanded a little
bit or if you actually just look at his
total liabilities its balance sheet grew
it took on some treasuries and i will
have a whole video on what the impact on
treasury interest rates that does
but in the process when it bought those
treasures in the open market more cash
got deposited into the banking system
and these could be this could be cash or
it could be reserved with the the
central bank but now let's think about
this this the situation between these
two banks now all of a sudden
this bank here needs less money right
because he got some reserve deposits
from our grandmothers
and also this bank now you know maybe
now this guy went from 10 percent maybe
now he has a 12 percent reserve ratio
because he got some deposits of actual
cash and maybe this guy went from 20
percent to i don't know 20
22 percent
so now this guy needs
less money right his his his his demand
for money has been lowered or for cash
has been lowered or his demand for
reserves has been lowered and this guy
has even more to land right he already
had a surplus and now he has even a
bigger surplus right so the supply of
reserves has increased in the banking
system
the supply has increased
from the lending bank and the demand
from the
borrowing bank has lowered so now if for
this transaction to occur the demand has
gone down the supply has gone up the
price has got to go down for borrowing
overnight and what is the price of
borrowing well that's interest rates so
now for this transaction to occur
all of a sudden maybe this guy needs it
less this guy wants to lend even more
because he has more so now maybe this
transaction will occur at an eight
percent interest rate
and maybe the fed has a target they they
have a target rate of five percent they
want to see a reality where this bank is
lending to that bank at a five percent
rate
so what would they do well they would
just keep doing this process they would
maybe they would issue a little bit more
i realized i'm enough time but you see
the process they'd issue some more notes
buy some more treasuries those notes
would end up in the banking system so
the demand for overnight lending will go
down and there'll be more of those
reserves out there so then the rate at
which people lend to each other will go
down anyway i'll see you in the next
video